this beach on Francis Atlantic coast is
a favorite spot for surfers from all
over Europe but now the soccer world cup
is on so they're in the mood for a
friendly with our world cup reporter Axl
cream amazing he quickly realizes that
playing on sand is almost as hard as it
is in Brazil's heat but soon he has to
move on he has an appointment to keep in
the village of Sue stall a few
kilometers inland
he's meeting who gobo Jay and Eric lakas
they get together with friends regularly
to watch their team's matches but axles
going to put the French fans World Cup
spirit to the test going into the last
match of their group phase against
Ecuador the prize question is will they
beat the Italians after all they lead
with 20 of 27 possible points so the
first round of our world cup spirit test
is strikers corner okay em in the other
countries strikers Kone always what's
the problem what about gold scoring and
you in France I don't know if we are
better than them maybe six for us we can
do it okay okay guys you can do it we
can do it
Eric's prediction was far off the mark
altogether he and his friends got only
two out of a possible nine goals man
just two points
so it's two at last yeah I think it's
not a good score I it's very sad for us
we will be better tonight I guess
Ecuadorian team of course we all the
toil after the BBQ that's probably just
an excuse but the friends don't care
joint meals are part of the world cup
atmosphere so you're not starving
anymore you're ready for the next round
of a welcome food test and I dress up
myself a little bit what do you think
about my outfit thank you thank you so
the next round is the quiz and three
questions three points for each correct
answer okay first question against whom
did france win the first and only World
Cup it's easy against brezin I guess
worth it i think yeah okay you sure
that's correct let's go in which year
did Xena deanzie damn play his last
World Cup match while I think it's in
2006 now I think I think that's correct
last question okay now it's getting a
bit more difficult which player scored
13 goals in one single World Cup this is
just fontaine you're really sure yeah
yeah correct the three are well prepared
for the last test they have to guess
who's who in the rival Ecuador national
team they get three points each time
they match a face to the right Jersey
you really ride
the three Frenchman got 20 points in the
euro max World Cup test in the end just
as many as the Italian fans and then the
match against Ecuador begins the end
result is a nil nil draw but the French
or through during the World Cup everyone
seems to love football everywhere and
consistent with the draw in the euro max
World Cup spirit test is the draw in the
match France against Ecuador but the
fancier they don't care they celebrate
the qualification for the round of 16
and this is what I'm going to do now as
well
you